what I thought your boy big snoop
d-o-double-g and this is the moment I
know when Kobe Bryant scored 13 points
in a row
the building was lit like as if we was
about to win the championship even
though it's your last game you see that
we knew what he wants to play out
but it just felt like it was the spirit
of us wanting championship between just
the way that everything came together
when his shop was heavy and just the way
that you know we knew that we had him
one more time to me I was looking at
like I've been to a lot of historic
moments but this is a historic moment in
basketballs gonna go down in a hundred
years from now and I'm actually in here
a part of it filming it right there in
the mix and I'm gonna be the DJ when the
night is over with everybody coming
upstairs to hang out with me
what does Kobe Bryant mean to me and how
he's impacted my fandom well I feel like
Kobe Bryant and me on a similar
wavelength his phones you know what we
represent is for his la the scene and
lifestyle him with basketball on me and
music and I just felt like you know our
friendship and our Brotherhood was
always shown it was always respecting it
was always mutual and I just love to see
him play because he brought a different
aspect of basketball to LA brought a
championship feeling back to the city
and he was always always in it to win it
I don't even know how to explain it I
just had to sit your hard ass down and
then you're gonna watch him game
together and after that late unless you
tell me what you just think I see seeing
is believing
and desperate to get to the basket of
the score my favorite moment memory
shared time with Kobe is um after he was
tired after this game he came to see me
about two weeks later you know when he
came to my facility he landed in a
helicopter and I picked him up in the
lowrider
and we was driving back spider lowriders
a Laker lowrider car too then we get
back to the spot
we jump out of life he's yours pal huh
this is you the show corner but I gave
you a lowrider phone he got the Snoop
Dogg like the lowrider
and he really been enjoying and that's
like a moment to me because I gave him
something that it's precious to me but
in it war to give it to him to let him
know how we appreciate it
anything he don't feel like a Laker
basketball nation just to sit better at
your house tomorrow what I thought your
boy big snoop d-o-double-g and this was
the moment I know I want to thank y'all
for tuning in be sure they're gonna pick
up my arm I want to thank me it's
available on all platforms right now
they tell them Snoop Dogg 6 you and
mother hey father hey kids